everyone welcome to another design
review this is partially part of our
season of version 14 design reviews and
one of four that we're doing
today so let's start off with the
longest shortest
story right so this is something we
discussed earlier this summer and we you
know so I one of the things was that we
should add uh some documentation
clarifying the situation so you should
you know check out
those uh those pages which are those are
links so that should work for you
um right so that I can't remember the
issue can you remind me the issue so
um right
so um when people
you uh well I mean one of the several
issues um is that uh you know um longest
and shortest sort of have different uh
meaning when it comes
to um optional when and
so
um when you um right so that's sort of
what we've had meaning here so rather
than sort of literally
meaning uh you know long or shortest uh
you know with longest it first attempts
to match the pattern and only then uses
the default if optional is
used
[Music]
um uh you know right so it's sort of uh
you know uh you know different from the
normal where where sort of shortest is
uh
um you know sort of the
default
and yes the level of uncertainty that
you're expressing in your voice and
talking about this is
disquieting what is the I mean you know
in other
words I you know okay who else who sorry
I'm I'm not
um did we make a change to the code here
or is this just a documentation change
this is just a documentation change
um right and so if you
um uh right look at sort of one of the
sort of the question that sort of
sparked this whole
investigation that's the why does longus
not help here
um
and
right if if you want to to I'm sorry
function wise we're not I'm this is all
incredibly obscure let me let me just
ask this
question we don't believe there's a
problem with functionality
correct
um if we don't believe there's a problem
with functionality this is pure
documentation if you guys think this
documentation helps the situation I'm
sure it's
fine I don't think we need to discuss
this here unless there's a question
about the
functionality okay
so all right so there is sort of a
bigger question about the functionality
which
is um I mean and there are a couple of
uh you know sort of points about here so
originally
um
uh optional required that there be you
know a blank inside of it you know um
you know not blank sequence
not anything else it had to you know it
could be any variety of blank but it had
to be exactly one blank um this wasn't
documented anywhere other than in an
error message but was it just an
implementation
limitation perhaps
um
and um right so now we right but in
particular this behavior of longest and
shortest made sense because you know
there were only two possible lengths
zero and one and so the these sort of
meanings of longest and shortest sort of
effectively made it made the blank
either not be used or be used and that
made sense and the fact that it was had
the defa you know opposite default made
sense because
that you know it would be stupid if you
always use the default and never the
thing inside of it
um um you know then we made this now we
didn't sort of intentionally change this
unless you know Danny has turned up
evidence that he did this intentionally
but right we did make this change in
version 10. something where you know the
default value didn't have to match match
the same
restrictions
[Music]
um uh as the the pattern right so you
could have like a blank string but the
default value could be
zero um and when he did that he also
allowed sort of more General patterns
but you know they're sort of edge cases
so for example uh you know there's that
bug listed there that you know if there
is at least some variety of you know
blank in there optional doesn't do what
you think and you know uh Nick ha Nick M
has some you know very in the last
section there has some very uh you know
obscure thing of using longest with
Alternatives and I don't even you know
we haven't defined what that means
uh uh and uh and we didn't have patent
sequence at the time when we invented
longest right and so you know do we want
to spend the time to Define what these
things mean I don't know um write the
second we don't right things for version
14 this is
not this is not a burning issue you know
yes I I I agree um the one thing is that
we might um right the one thing that we
might want to think about is whether the
you know the the requiring the
blank is is that something is that a bug
of something other than P5 or is that um
look this needs somebody to dig in and
you know I think this is a a when the
pattern matcher is Rewritten we should
rethink this
okay and I don't think it's a you know I
I just don't think this is a corner case
of a corner
case it's all right yeah I suspect I've
been bitten by this because I've you
know randomly used longest and shortest
for things and I
don't understand what they do in the
context of triple blanks and things but
you know I just keep on poking it until
it works and that's not great and and I
think when we rewrite the pattern
matcher we need to look at the small C
definely but I think anything that we
try and do other than that is going to
be a hack job because we haven't really
dug in and understand the full context
of it and I think it's better not to do
anything and just to add
documentation okay well then yes and and
since which is you know a a perfectly
reasonable place that uh you know I I
was hoping to get to the main thing I as
you know that was the sort of level of
decision I wanted and you know if you're
okay with I think I'm okay with that not
committing in this new documentation to
something that we're going to regret
later I I don't think we are okay
fine okay Trace original to
automatic so I mean I've been Now using
sorry can I leave because I was you were
there for the first thing do you have
anything to say the first thing I mean
I'll be reading email so do you have
anything to say about the first thing
before we close it off
no I I I agree with everything that you
were saying I mean there is a detailed
analysis and we can have simpler or more
difficult examples but I agree with what
what you decided I think that's all
right fine see you Tom then
okay
okay I mean isn't this an Ian production
this Trace original thing no it's Ian is
the user of this in Trace graph correct
right so so I mean Danny did the
implementation Ian is the consumer and
they're both here and you know we have
some some pretty examples there for
you um you
know this is perfectly
reasonable okay and you know if you're
okay with the note that Ian I think I am
yeah this looks
reasonable
okay
oh boy yeah so this John will need to
take over here because I'm not sure I
fully Gro yeah okay so well first of all
you can open up the documentation for
Notebook
import which version let's see where do
I need to go uh it I mean this has been
around for a while for a few released
versions now I just open generic Port by
the way I found a horrible thing with
with
them I've got a a raft failure
again
okay I have notebook
import I get a raft it's all good I open
the thing up to this now oh oh my gosh
the raft goes away I'm about to type an
argument which is exactly when I need
the raft and kabum asaurus the raft goes
away that is not a life raft I it
is this isn't a new newly reported thing
you you mentioned this in the last user
assistance meeting we talked about this
okay all right this particular thing I
mean I don't even necessarily think
that's wrong it's not that's wrong okay
all right let's not cover this right now
the okay notebook and Port okay so if
you open up the details in options
section you'll see that we already have
a thing we we have two options
documented here uh interestingly both of
the options are in their string forms um
because they're not used elsewhere and I
don't know because people are being lazy
or something I don't know um
so uh okay so flatten cell groups is
already a thing that works for notbook
import I'm not proposing any changes for
Notebook
import uh what I am proposing is that
flatten cell groups it can become an
interesting option for a couple of other
functions um uh for
cells uh it could do EXA exactly what it
does for Notebook import right now which
is just a wrap nested lists around cell
groups nested lists or or flattened I
don't understand well so it well flatten
cell grips is true by
default uh so by default you get you you
get things flattened but you can set it
to false if you want the cell groups by
cell groups we mean that it is a cell
inside a cell like this yes yes I don't
think it's really flatten cell groups
what I think it really is
sorry sorry not a not
a sorry I don't actually know what you
mean by a cell inside a cell in terms
yeah yeah but I mean that is that is how
we represent the serialization of cell
groups I mean I know yeah I know but
what I'm saying
is what flatten cell groups is doing is
taking this out from being a nested cell
object and turning it into a well well
take take a look at that first output of
notebook import where I've set flatten
cell groups to
false if I hadn't set flatten cell
groups you would have just gotten a flat
list because it's true by default but by
setting it to false notice that it
nests the in this case input and output
cells together which which are
grouped I understand in other words it
gives okay here it's just using lists
for nesting just to be simple I think
you know because notebook import wanted
to you know produce simple results as
opposed to what well as opposed to what
notebook read does which is you know
High Fidelity but requires High degree
of knowledge of what's going
on okay so let me just understand the
issue
is if you use use nested lists for cell
groups then the head group of a
cell appears
where the the the I that statement
didn't make sense the head I don't know
what you mean by head group of a cell
like the section cell I think yeah the
section heading cell the head cell the
head cell of a group you mean yes right
okay so right now cell group
data
the cell group data contains the group
of cells right and the out outside
cell is the head cell is that not
correct no that is not correct the the
cell group data contains everything
including the head cell what's the
syntax of cell group data so cell group
data takes two arguments the first
argument is a list uh of of cell
expressions and then the second argument
is the state of the cell is it open or
closed and and uh or reverse closed or
that sort of thing okay all right so in
the flattened cell groups but but but
the thing is that cell group data never
appears nakedly cell group data always
appears inside of a cell expression why
uh because that's the syntax that was
agreed upon before I started working on
the front end
as you know that goes pretty far back
yeah okay so this is 35y
old so I mean I mean the the reasoning I
think was back in the day uh that um uh
that the first you know that you had
postcript data and Text data and box
data and bitmap data uh and all these
were kind of different cell types you
know the idea was each thing was a
different cell type and so then the
question was how to represent cell
groups and you know in hindsight I I
don't fully agree with this decision but
we've been doing it forever so I don't
want to change it uh we said well let's
just call that cell group data and like
everything else it would be wrapped by a
cell even though there isn't actually a
cell around it it it's only wrapped by a
cell in the
serialization
oh well I mean the seral ation we can't
change I guess it's some you know and
that's and we have great compatibility
for 35 years yeah and and and this is
why notebook import you know aspires in
in the flatten sers false case to do
something much simpler which is just use
sublists well how does it
know I don't understand that notebook
import it it it should be said notbook
import is just giving you the grouping
data it's not giving you the state of
the groups
uh presumably no really cares if you're
dealing with notebook import I'm not
sure that's true well it well my point
being that if you cared to that degree
you would go to notebook read Because
notebook read is the high fidelity no
data loss I could argue that notebook
import I assume Lou is here The Notebook
import L Lou Lou is not here but I but
Lou and I have talked but Lou and I have
talked about this all right but but I
mean to me there should be a version of
notebook import that says get me only
the visible
cells uh no one has ever asked for that
I can imagine that being useful because
that's the get me every cell and get me
only the cells that are open
visible those are not the same thing
visible and open yeah I get it I get it
but I mean the
the that that's a fin of gradation but I
mean get me all the cells I can see and
now the question here is do I want them
as the High Fidelity notebook read thing
or do I want them as nested
lists well and and and the whole idea of
notebook import is I I mean you could in
principle have always done the sorts of
things you do with notebook import but
notebook import is trying to lower the
bar I know I know I know I know I know I
know I know the only thing that we're
okay it's returning a list of cells
right and it's presumably returning when
if you say uh text right so right so you
have two two inout groups in this in
this thing yes and and you get a list of
two of two lists correct right
and right so so presumably you
know I'm sorry what's happening here why
did oh was just slow as hell uh well it
was calling notebook evaluate to and I'm
not sure why the notebook evaluate
sometimes is is a bit pricity in that
regard I'm not sure if that's what
happened or not so this is what we see
here yes and if I say I'm totally
confused by this I'm totally confused so
it it yeah so now now that's the default
Behavior you you could actually remove
the option and you would get the same
behavior um okay the default behavior is
just bring in the cells in the order
they appear in the notebook I don't care
how they're grouped
correct okay so I
think I'm and to be clear I'm not asking
to change any of this for Notebook
import I'm just explaining it because I
want to add functionality to similar
functionality to other
functions yeah I understand I
understand which I think is fine but I I
don't this name is really doesn't work
and this name doesn't work and the fact
that it's a string doesn't
work clearly
uh and I would and I would happily throw
myself on on my sword if I were involved
in the base design of this function but
somehow I got cut out of the design so I
don't think we ever I think it was
viewed as an experimental function which
I I don't know why it isn't whatever
that this this should have been changed
but anyway never mind I I I agree and
I'm willing to make that happen pending
this discussion okay all right fine okay
so what would be guys can can we please
just focus on what we're actually trying
to deal with here look what we got go
ahead well I I am trying to understand
how this name Will to other functions
and in
particular the name is no good exactly
well which is why I'm trying to
understand how this will affect other
functions so for example in Notebook
read uh what will it do well
so it so it first of all in Notebook
read its default would be different
because we can't change notebook read
notebook reads obvious fall Behavior but
uh but what I'm proposing is that uh if
you set flatten cell groups or whatever
we call it to
true then it wouldn't give you any of
that cell group data stuff at all it
would simply give you a list of cell
Expressions much like you know what we
just saw with notebook
import okay right in which case I feel
like flatten cell so if in in the
notebook import case if if you evaluated
that third input in the first input cell
W without the
notebook without the flattened cell
groups would you get basically the same
thing as notebook read with a cell of
cell group data of blah blah blah
correct yeah in which case I feel like
flatten cell groups is the completely
wrong name right because it's like right
it's
your
uh it's not really flattening it's like
removing or groups as groups as yes yes
you are correct it's basically stripping
them yeah well so why why don't we have
you know preserve grouping preserve cell
grouping or you know true or false strip
cell
grouping
well I don't think we need two I two op
one or the other
right I mean strip you know we have
these things what is it called stripon
what is it called stripon input trip on
input yeah why am I not finding this in
in in why am I not finding that
um it's a pretty lowlevel option it it's
possible that it's been omitted
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait look
look look what's going on
here um it's showing up in my
completion maybe you have enough like
package symbols that
are uh this is a prototype build so I
don't know what I think it's just a bug
so needs to be looked at no no it isn't
that's 131 13
through3 okay somebody's got to I think
it's losing to all the string P
functions
right sensitive completion and it it
gets downrank because it's an option and
you're typing an option name why is it
not Oh you mean mean it is there we just
need to get past the P oh I see because
those are all string P things
oh stupid no no no no no that's not
stupid at all all right okay okay okay
okay it's highly intelligent
actually and and it's doing exactly what
you wanted which is to sort of you know
not insist on matching cases if we
default it to you know match all right
okay okay okay okay I'm going to stop
complaining about that for a second okay
so then strip sell strip what do we call
cell what is the grouping
option strip cell
grouping um let's see we have a a couple
of yeah we have cell
grouping uh whole cell group opener uh
cell grouping rules uh we're definitely
using the phrase cell group or cell
grouping in in all these
cases strip cell grouping is perfectly
reasonable I I'd be happy with
that okay then let's go with this I mean
strip C grouping them and then that can
work in all these different cases all
right let's while we're at it so so it
would default to true for uh notbook
import and cells and it Woulda to false
for Notebook read sounds right to me
okay okay what's this one
here um
so
uh so this is basically something that
allows you to well it go down to the
options examples I think that might be
the best place to to look it up
um so it's basically you know a way
to um it's basically a way to customize
you know instead of having the same rule
apply to each every cell have different
rules for different uh uh cell
Styles and why don't we call it cell
style import
rules do we have an analogy with that
with import
somehow H not with
Imports
um yeah definitely not with import um
because right that's
uh um
what might be a
related
context um well I I'd be okay with sell
style import rules okay and I can I can
write that up as well I'm happy to do so
okay that that's my piece thanks thanks
see
you you know I asked uh I asked Ian if I
was clear enough and he told me I needed
an an additional exclamation point to
properly convey my feelings so that's
why there are four there so here's the
issue what is a good mechanism I've got
an
expression and I just want to store it
in the cloud so I can retrieve it at
some later time and I just want a uu ID
for it I just want to handle maybe
there's a different mechanism for doing
it maybe it's create Cloud expression I
don't know is that the right thing I
mean why why is this not like Cloud put
I mean I mean it it is cloud putut this
literally works with Cloud put and and
and I was I was in a previous discussion
with you about this and you thought that
cloud putut didn't work one argument
Cloud put didn't work but it
does and now if I say get of that yep
okay I'm I'm just confuzzled okay ignore
it this
okay just let's make sure that there's a
the cloud export points to Cloud putut
okay
um okay there right so there there are a
couple of you know wrinkles there you
know we we discussed this at some point
and decided it wouldn't be useful but we
didn't record why and I was unable I'm
supposed to go to some other meeting in
just a couple minutes here um I mean if
you want to punt on this till next time
but but the idea was Nest F2 of
X right it's like f to the power two com
you know compose F twice and apply it to
X yep I mean I I I understand what the
the proposal is um you know we decided
at some point it wouldn't be useful like
I said we didn't record why um you know
one possible issue is that NES graph and
nestry document the two AR form to
basically be do it one step so this
would be
inconsistent um I don't think that's a
huge problem although I think the do it
one step thing is a bit weird
anyway yeah
[Music]
um right and you know if we wanted to
extend this to all of The Nest things
then you know right we would only be
able to do the most basic of the nest
Wilds as an operator form right because
they're distinguished by additional AR I
don't think we need Nest wild as an
opera form I think the point here is
merely the the um the straightforward
thing of of you know functional square
of
F and so would it actually evaluate to F
compose
F that's interesting or composition F
comma
I don't think so I don't think so I
think it would be just an operative form
that just sits there symbolically that's
the most useful thing
yeah I mean I right if we do Nest we
should all also do Nest list uh
because but sure you know if if if if
we're okay with them being different
from the nest tree and we're ignoring
this while I don't think I mean Danny do
you have any comments on
or I don't see any Earthly reason why we
really want this because I than it can
make very nice elegant code that's the
reason that's why I want it just for
code
Elegance I got a all right see you guys
bye